[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
i'm arl stein and i'm delighted to read
chapter 9
of coraline by neil gaiman
outside the world had become a formless
swirling mist
with no shapes or shadows behind it
while the house itself
seemed to have twisted and stretched it
seemed to coraline that it was crouching
and staring down at her as if it were
not really a house but only the idea of
a house
and the person who had had the idea she
was certain
was not a good person there was sticky
web stuff
clinging to her arm and she wiped it off
as best she could
the gray windows of the house slanted at
strange angles
the other mother was waiting for her
standing on the grass with her arms
folded
her black button eyes were
expressionless but her lips were pressed
tightly together
in a cold fury when she saw
coraline she reached out one long white
hand
and she crooked a finger coraline walked
toward her
the other mother said nothing i got two
said coraline
one soul still to go the expression on
the other mother's face
did not change she might not have heard
what coraline said
well i just thought you'd want to know
said coraline
thank you coraline said the other mother
coldly
and her voice did not just come from her
mouth
it came from the mist and the fog and
the house in the sky
she said you know that i love you
and despite herself coraline nodded it
was true
the other mother loved her but she loved
coraline
as a miser loves money or a dragon loves
its gold
in the other mother's button eyes
coraline knew
that she was a possession nothing more
a tolerated pet whose behavior was
no longer amusing i don't want your love
sid coraline i don't want anything from
you
not even a helping hand ask the other
mother
you have been doing so well after all i
thought you might want a little hint
to help you with the rest of your
treasure hunt
i'm doing fine on my own said coraline
yes said the other mother but if you
wanted to get into the flat
in the front the empty one to look
around
you would find the door locked and then
where would you be
oh coraline pondered this for a moment
then she said is there a key
the other mother stood there in the
paper gray fog of the flattening world
her black hair drifted about her head as
if it had a mind and a purpose all of
its own
she coughed suddenly in the back of her
throat and then she opened her mouth
the other mother reached up her hand and
removed a small
brass front door key from her tongue
here she said you'll need this to get in
she tossed the key casually toward
coraline
who caught it one-handed before she
could think about whether she wanted it
or not
the key was still slightly damp
a chill wind blew about them and
coraline shivered and looked away when
she looked back
she was alone uncertainly she walked
around to the front of the house
and stood in front of the door to the
empty flat
like all the doors it was painted bright
green
she doesn't mean you well whispered a
ghost voice in her ear
we do not believe that she would help
you it must be a trick
coraline said yes you're right i expect
then she put the key in the lock and
turned it silently the door
swung open and silently coraline walked
inside
the flat head walls the color of old
milk
the wooden boards of the floor were
uncarpeted and dusty
with the marks and patterns of old
carpets and rugs on them
there was no furniture in there only
places where furniture had once been
nothing decorated the walls there were
discolored rectangles on the walls to
show
where paintings or photographs it once
hung
it was so silent that coraline imagined
that she could hear the motes of
dust drifting through the air
she found herself to be quite worried
that something would jump
out at her so she began to whistle she
thought it might make it harder for
things to jump
out at her if she was whistling first
she walked through the empty kitchen
then she walked through an empty
bathroom containing only a cast iron
bath
and in the bath a dead spider the size
of a small
cat the last room she looked
at had she supposed once been a bedroom
she could imagine that the rectangular
dust shadow on the floorboards
had once been a bed then she saw
something and smiled grimly
set into the floorboards was a large
metal ring
coraline knelt and took the cold ring in
her hands
and she tugged upward as hard as she
could
terribly slowly stiffly heavily
a hinged square of floor lifted it was a
trap door
it lifted and through the opening
coraline could see
only darkness she reached down and her
hand found a cold
switch she flicked it without much hope
that it would work
but somewhere below her a bulb lit
and a thin yellow light came up from the
hole in the floor
she could see steps heading down but
nothing else
coraline put her hand into her pocket
and took out the stone with the hole in
it she looked through it
at the cellar but saw nothing she put
the stone back into her pocket
up through the hole came the smell of
damp clay
and something else an acrid tang
like sour vinegar coraline let herself
down into the hole
looking nervously at the trapdoor it was
so heavy that if it fell
she was sure she'd be trapped down in
the darkness forever
she put a hand and touched it
but it stayed in position and then she
turned toward the darkness below and she
walked down the steps
set into the wall at the bottom of the
steps was another light switch
metal and rusting she pushed it until it
clicked down
and a naked bulb hanging from a wire
from the low
ceiling came on it didn't give up enough
light even for coraline to make out the
things that had been painted
onto the flaking cellar walls the
painting seemed
crude there were eyes she could see and
things that might have been grapes and
other things below them
coraline could not be sure that there
were paintings of people
there was a pile of rubbish in one
corner of the room
cardboard boxes filled with mildewed
papers
and decaying curtains in a heap beside
them
coraline slippers crunched across the
cement floor
the bad smell was worse now she was
ready to turn and leave
when she saw the foot sticking out for
behind the pile of curtains
she took a deep breath the smells of
sour
wine and moldy bread filled her head and
she pulled away the damp cloth
to reveal something more or less the
size and shape of a person
in that dim light it took her several
seconds to recognize it
for what it was the thing was pale and
swollen
like a grub with thin stick-like arms
and feet
it had almost no features on its face
which it puffed and swollen
like risen bread dough the thing had two
large black
buttons where its eyes should have been
coraline made a noise the sound of
revulsion
and horror and as if it hurt her
and awakened the thing began to sit up
coraline stood there frozen the thing
turned its head
until both its black button eyes were
pointed straight at her
a mouth opened in the mouthless face
strands of pale
stuff sticking to the lips and a voice
that no longer
even faintly resembled her father's
whispered
coraline well said coraline to the thing
that had once been her other father
at least you didn't jump out at me
the creature's twig like hands moved to
its face and pushed the pale clay about
making something like a nose it said
nothing
i'm looking for my parents at coraline
or a stolen soul
from one of the other children are they
down here
there is nothing down here said the pale
thing
nothing but dust and damp and forgetting
the thing was white and huge and swollen
monstrous thought coraline but also
miserable
she raised the stone with the hole in it
to her eye and looked through it nothing
the pale thing was telling her the truth
poor thing she said
i bet she made you come down here as a
punishment for telling me too much
the thing hesitated then it nodded
coraline wondered how she could ever
have imagined that this grub-like thing
resembled her father
i'm so sorry she said she's not best
pleased
said the thing that was once her older
father not best pleased at all
you put her quite out of sorts and when
she gets out of sorts she takes it out
on everybody else
it's her way coraline patted its
hairless head
its skin was tacky like a warm bread
dough
poor thing she said you're just a thing
she made and then threw away
the thing nodded vigorously as if nodded
the left button eye fell off and
clattered onto the concrete floor
the thing looked around vacantly with
its one eye as if it had lost her
finally it saw her and as if making a
great effort it opened its mouth once
more
and said in a wet urgent voice run child
leave this place she wants me to hurt
you to keep you here forever
so that you can never finish the game
and she will win
she's pushing me so hard to hurt you i
cannot fight her
you can said coraline be brave
she looked around the thing had once
been the other father
it was between her and the steps up and
out of the cellar
she started edging along the wall
heading toward the steps
the thing twisted bonelessly until its
one eye was again facing her
it seemed to be getting bigger and more
awake
alas it said i cannot and it lunged
across the cellar toward her then
its toothless mouth opened wide
coreline had a single heartbeat in which
to react
she could only think of two things to do
either she could scream and try to run
away
and be chased around a badly lit cellar
by the huge
grub thing be chased until it caught her
or she could do something else so she
did
something else as the thing reached her
coraline put out her hand and closed it
around the thing's remaining button eye
and she tugged as hard as she knew how
for a moment nothing happened then the
button came away
and flew from her hand clicking against
the walls before it fell to the cellar
floor
the thing froze in place it threw its
pale head back
blindly and opened its mouth horribly
wide
and it roared its anger and frustration
then all in a rush the thing swept
toward the place where coraline had been
standing
but coraline was not standing there any
longer she was already tiptoeing
as quietly as she could up the steps
that would take her away
from the dim cellar and the crude
paintings on the wall
she couldn't take her eyes from the
floor beneath her though
across which the pale thing flopped and
ride
hunting for her then as if it was being
told what to do the creature stopped
moving
and its blind head tipped to one side
it's listening for me thought coraline i
must be extra quiet
she took another step up and her foot
slipped on the step
and the thing hurt her its head tipped
toward her
for a moment it swayed and seemed to be
gathering its wits
then fast as a serpent it slithered for
the steps and began to flow up them
toward her coraline turned and ran
wildly
up the last half dozen steps and she
pushed hers
pushed herself up and onto the floor the
dusty bedroom
without pausing she pulled the heavy
trap door toward her
and let go of it it crashed down with a
thump
just as something large banged against
it
the trapdoor shook and rattled in the
floor
but it stayed where it was coraline took
a deep breath
if there had been any furniture in that
flat even a chair
she would have pulled it onto the
trapdoor but there was nothing
she walked out of that flat as fast as
she could without actually ever running
and she locked the front door behind her
she left the door key under the mat
then she walked down onto the drive
she had half expected the other mother
would be standing there
waiting for coraline to come out but the
world was silent and empty
coraline wanted to go home she hugged
herself
and told herself that she was brave and
she almost believed herself
and then she walked around to the side
of the house
in the gray mist that wasn't a mist
and she made for the stairs to go up
[Music]
you